.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
SO YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THIS VIDEO,
AN AMAZON DELIVERY DRIVER IN
APPLE VALLEY, CALIFORNIA,
DROPPING OFF PACKAGES WHEN HE
STEPS AND FALLS INSIDE ASEPTIC
TANK.
IT HAPPENED LAST WHILE.
WHILE HE WAS STUCK, THE DRIVER
UPLOADED THIS VIDEO.
>> SO I WAS DELIVERING TO THIS
CUSTOMER'S HOUSE AND I JUST FELL
INTO A SEPTIC TANK.
I THINK IT -- I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY WERE DIGGING IT OR WHAT AND
I WALKED BY IT AND THE GROUND
CAME OUT UNDERNEATH ME.
I'M LIKE SIX FEET DOWN.
I TRIED USING THESE ROOTS AROUND
ME TO GET OUT.
IT JUST PULLED MORE DIRT ON TOP
OF ME.
I JUST CALLED DISPATCH.
HOPEFULLY THEY'RE GOING TO GET
THE COPS OR THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
HERE BECAUSE I DEFINITELY DON'T
WANT TO TRY TO CLIMB OUT ON MY
OWN AGAIN BECAUSE LIKE I SAID,
THE WALLS ARE KIND OF CAVING IN
ON ME A LITTLE BIT SCARY.
>> Tucker: SO THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT DID COME AND RESCUE
THAT MAN.
AND HERE'S THE THING.
AT A MOMENT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
DISMISSING AMERICAN WORKERS AS
LAYSO OR DISENGAGED, THAT MAN
TOOK A SHOWER AND THEN CONTINUED
HIS ROUTE!
WE WERE VERY IMPRESSED WITH
THAT.
IN FACT, WE GAVE HIM THE
EMPLOYEE OF THE MONTH HONORS AND
THEN WE FOUND HIM.
HIS NAME IS CHARLES AND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
CHARLES, I -- I'M SO IMPRESSED
BY THIS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
UM --
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: YOU FELL INTO THIS
LIKE A TIGER TRAP WITHOUT SEEING
IT?
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> UM, NO, ACTUALLY I DID SEE
THE HOLE.
I WALKED BY IT ON MY WAY TO
DELIVER A PACKAGE AND THEN I
WALKED BY IT AGAIN ON MY WAY
BACK TO MY VEHICLE.
AND THE GROUND NEXT TO THE HOLE
IS WHAT COLLAPSED UNDERNEATH ME,
EVEN THOUGH I KEPT A BIT OF A
DISTANCE FROM THE HOLE.
I STILL MANAGED TO FALL IN
BECAUSE THE GROUND COLLAPSED
UNDERNEATH MY FEET.
AND ALSO I WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
CONFIRMED WITH ME THAT THE DROP
WASN'T SIX FEET, IT WAS ACTUALLY
13 FEET.
>> Tucker: THAT'S
UNBELIEVABLE!
UM, SO I'M SURE YOU SEE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS TO YOUR ROUTE
EVERY DAY.
I MEAN IT -- FAMOUSLY, IT'S AN
INTERESTING JOB.
WEIRD PEOPLE... DOGS.
HAVE YOU EVER FALLEN INTO A DEEP
HOLE BEFORE?
>> THIS IS NOT SOMETHING I WOULD
HAVE EVER IMAGINED HAPPENING,
NO, TUCKER.
I DON'T THINK OTHER DELIVERY
DRIVERS WOULD EITHER.
>> Tucker: YOUR COOLNESS UNDER
PRESSURE INSPIRES THE REST OF
US.
ALSO YOUR COMMITMENT TO YOUR
JOB.
ONCE YOU FALL INTO A 13-FOOT
SEPTIC HOLE, YOU KIND OF DESERVE
THE DAY OFF.
PEOPLE TAKE HOLIDAYS OFF I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF BEFORE.
DID YOU CONSIDER CALLING IT A
DAY AND HAVING A BEER?
>> I DID CONSIDER IT.
I THINK THERE WAS -- THERE WAS
SEVERAL THINGS THAT CAUSED ME TO
DECIDE TO GO AHEAD AND FINISH
THE ROUTE, AND, YOU KNOW, IT WAS
PROBABLY -- I WAS ON A GOOD
ADRENALINE RUSH.
YOU KNOW, MY TIME IN THE MARINE
CORPS, YOU KNOW, AS A MARINE,
WE'RE CONDITIONED TO ALWAYS
ACCOMPLISH OUR MISSION.
THAT WAS GOING IN MY HEAD.
ANOTHER BIG THING IS HAD I NOT
COMPLETED MY ROTORUA TEMPTED TO
AT LEAST, OTHER DRIVERS WHO HAD
ALREADY BEEN OUT THERE AND DONE
THEIR ENTIRE ROUTES WOULD GET
STUCK HAVING TO FINISH MY ROUTE
AND I JUST DIDN'T THINK THAT
WOULD BE FAIR TO THEM EITHER.
BUT I DID VOLUNTARILY OFFER TO
TAKE MY ROUTE SO --
>> Tucker: I HOPE YOU WERE
REWARDED FOR IT.
YOU CERTAINLY HAVE OUR
ADMIRATION F